So imagine this,
you know,
you get up in the morning,
you do a bunch of things and someone
asks you what you're doing,
what you did and you,
you know,
you tell them,
well the first thing I did this morning
was open my eyes and the second thing
was thinking about whether I wanted to
go back to sleep and then,
you know,
I took off my blankets and then I put my
feet on the floor and then I stood up
and I was blinking while I was doing all
this and I was also breathing.
And then,
you know,
I looked for my claw and you really want
to listen to that guy.
You don't want to listen to that guy.
It's like,
why do you,
why are you telling me that?
I want you to tell me something
interesting.
Well,
what is it that's interesting and why
isn't that interesting?
It's not obvious.
So,
so then imagine the guy actually tells
you a pretty good story and a little
adventure.
Probably he was doing something normal.
Something unexpected happened.
He had to conjure up some new responses
and he either settled the problem or
didn't settle the problem.
Yeah,
you're interested in that.
Especially if he settled the problem
because if he can tell you how when he
encountered some unexplored territory,
he was able to sew it back together,
then maybe you can do that when that
thing happens and how it's pretty cheap
wisdom for you.
It's.
He had to go through all the aggravation
of figuring it out.
No,
you have to do is listen.
You know,
and that's kind of a classic story.
Classic Story.
Roughly speaking is there's a guy or
woman,
doesn't matter,
go into both their life relatively
normally,
something blindsides them and they're in
a state of chaos.
Chaos is the place.
Chaos is the place that you end up when
what you're doing and the world stopped
matching and the chaos can be of
different degrees.
You know,
you could wake up and find that your
house was burgled and you could wake up
and find that a parent has your parent
has Alzheimer's or some fatal disease or
that you do,
or that your whole family was murdered
or that there's a war starting or you
know there's different degrees of chaos
and I think you can quantify the chaos
by calculating how much of what you do
and expect is likely to be disrupted by
the event now because that the more
disruption,
the more destabilized you're going to
be,
which is why if,
if someone tells you that you're going
to perish painfully in three months,
it's like that's a bad one.
You're really in an unexpected territory
there.
Nothing that you assumed that was real.
Roughly speaking in the world is real
anymore.
We like to watch people in their normal
life blindsided by something,
experiencing this inter regnum of where
they explore and gather new information
and retooled their character or retool
the world because you could either of
those would work as a solution and then
come out the other side and things are
better than they were to begin with,
or at least as good,
but better is better.
That's a happy ending,
right?
That's a happy ending.
That's a comedy,
technically speaking,
and so
what you want.
You want your life to be a comedy.
Not that it's supposed to be funny
because comedy doesn't have to be funny
technically speaking.
It's just the opposite of tragedy.
Tragedy is when you're going along
pretty well and you get blindsided and
that's that and you know that can
certainly happen.
It happens to people all the time,
but it's a comedy you want.
Now what I hope to provide you with,
is there a magic code?
You know,
there was a book published a while back.
Tom Hanks was in the movie who was a
harvard professor who went around
solving symbolic mysteries.
Do you remember what?
What was it called,
the Davinci Code.
Everyone liked that.
It sold a lot and you know,
it was a little mysteries and it's full
of hints that there was more to the
world than you think and which is
definitely true and that,
you know,
there was a way of getting access to
that knowledge and then it would really
be worthwhile and people liked that.
They liked that idea.
And the reason for that is because it's
actually,
it's true,
it's true.
It's true.
Like,
like fiction is true.
So okay,
let's go back to the guy who's telling
you about his morning.
Well,
he tells you something exciting.
Well then imagine that 10 people tell
you something exciting and then you
extract out the pattern of them dealing
with this problem from that.
And so then you have a.
that's what you do if you're an author,
right?
Because in a,
in a book,
you don't want the book exactly to be
about what ordinary people do in
ordinary times in their life.
It's like you already know how to be
ordinary during ordinary times of your
life.
What?
That's not useful.
You know,
you wouldn't watch a video tape of
yourself.
Imagine you videotaped yourself during a
day and then the next day you watched
that.
It's like God,
who would want to do that?
So what seems to happen in stories is
that they distill,
they distill,
so they watch people,
people watch people and then they tell
stories about what they see,
but they leave a lot out of those
stories.
Everything that's boring hopefully,
and then more and more stories about
exciting things get sort of aggregated
and then maybe a great writer comes
along and write something really,
really interesting,
profound character transformations,
and then you say,
well,
that's fiction.
And then you say,
well,
that's not true because it's fiction,
but then then maybe that's not right.
Maybe it's more than true because who
wants the truth?
The truth is mundane reality and you've
already got that mastered.
What you want is the distillation of
interesting experience and you might
think,
well,
why is it interesting?
Well,
that's a really good question because
you don't actually know and believe me,
you really don't know because you'll be
interested in things that just don't
make any sense at all.
I'm going to walk you a bit today
through Pinocchio and we'll do that more
the next time to,
you know,
but I want to tell you a little bit
about that movie to begin with,
just so you know,
how crazy you are.
So you know the plot.
How many people have seen the Disney
movie?
Pinocchio?
Okay.
So lots of people.
So that's strange enough in itself that
so many people have seen it and it's
worth thinking about.
You know,
you tend to show your kids that moody
and.
But do you think about the movie?
It's,
you're doing some pretty weird things
when you're sitting there watching that
movie,
man,
first of all,
it's drawings,
right?
And they're low resolution drawings.
You don't care.
And you watch the simpsons or maybe fit
or a.
what's that called?
The the one that's been concentrating on
political correctness so much south
park.
God,
that animation man,
it's just awful,
right?
It's just horrible.
It couldn't be worse.
You don't care like round heads smile,
a little bit of shuffling.
That's a person as far as your concern
is just irrelevant.
And if it was higher resolution it
wouldn't help.
You just need the bare bones,
right?
Dang your perceptions on.
So.
So you watch this drawing that's been
oakeel beautiful drawings,
animated in a sequence.
You don't watching something real,
you're watching a pure construction and
then you think about the plot.
It's like it's completely absurd.
Everything about it is observed.
It's like,
well one of the characters is a bug and
he turns out to be like the conscience
and so what the hell is up with that?
And then another character is this
puppet Marionette and you know,
somehow he gets free of his strings and
then goes on this adventure and then
which is.
And then he gets enticed into various
nefarious places by a Fox and a cat.
And then he rescues his father from a
whale and you don't even know I was
father God in the way.
Oh,
it's like the last time you see his
father,
he was in a rainstorm and the next thing
that happens is he's in a whale and
you're sitting there thinking,
Hey,
no problem.
This all makes sense.
It's like,
what?
Really?
Why?
How does that make sense?
Well,
the answer is you don't know.
That's the thing that's so cool.
You don't know.
You don't even know what you're,
but it doesn't matter.
You Watch it and you're interested in
it.
You want to see what the hell happens to
this puppet.
You want to see if he ends up becoming a
real boy because there's.
It's seems important.
Well,
I to say,
well,
let's Pinocchio.
True.
Oh,
that's a stupid question.
It's partly a stupid question because
the answer is it depends what you mean
by true
and
it isn't obvious to me what you should
mean
when you
say that something's true and I.
The reason it's not obvious is because
we have this idea in our society and
it's.
It's a very profound idea and that idea
is that the ultimate truth is scientific
truth that that tells us that about the
nature of the world and it does that in
a final way.
In some sense there is no brooking any
arguments about it and the physicists
have got it right and that's why they
can make hydrogen bombs and that's a
pretty good demonstration of their being
right,
but you don't act as if that's true
and you don't,
and you watch things and pay attention
to things in are captivated by things
that aren't predicated on those
assumptions and it seems to me that
there is a problem of what the world is
made out of,
but there's a bigger problem and that's
the problem of how you should conduct
yourself in the world.
And that's really what you want to know.
People want to know that more than
anything because you need to know.
It's like here you guys are in
university.
It's like you don't know what you're
doing.
I mean,
some of you know more than others,
but you're at the beginning of your life
and life is very complex and chaotic and
it isn't exactly obvious.
You know,
how,
what kind of relationship you should
form or what sort of character you
should develop or what you're going to
do for a job or how.
What's the meaning of life?
That's a good one.
Well,
and you know,
people come to university,
at least many of them and that's kind of
what they want to find out.